okay let's talk about something I've
been getting a lot of questions about
over the last couple of weeks and the
gist of the questions has been hey David
why are you listed on Jordan Peterson's
new website think spot why are you
involved with Jordan Peterson are you
part of it are you not part of it I've
not heard you mention it but they list
you so let's talk about it I haven't
been saying anything publicly because
there's been a lot going on behind the
scenes but I am ready to talk to you
today about it and I can report to you
that I am no longer in any way part of
Jordan Peterson's website think spot but
I do believe I owe you a full
explanation about everything that's gone
down and I'll tell you about it today so
months and months ago in fact it was on
July 2nd
Jordan Peterson emailed me and said hey
David I'm starting this thing think spot
with some other people we're bringing in
a bunch of high-profile contributors I
thought of you here's an introduction to
the people running it talked to them and
I had no further contact with Jordan
Peterson I was put in touch with the
folks at think spot all nice people the
idea was hey we're bringing in a bunch
of big-name contributors to our website
thanks but we want you to be on there
you can do whatever you want of course
whatever content you already do or want
to start doing or whatever you can do so
I of course have done a ton of
criticisms and takedowns of Jordan
Peterson and so when I was approached I
thought either he and they have no idea
about that when they invited me or they
have an idea and they don't care either
way it's not my problem so I thought
what is my philosophy on the show about
appearing on different platforms my
philosophy on this show has been when I
am invited to a new platform if it's not
a lot more work for our team because we
are stretched pretty thin I do it and
we've launched on a ton of different
platforms over the last few years we
launched on a platform called steam it
we launched our podcast on Pandora and
Spotify and radio.com we started putting
our clips on D Tube and another one
called library lb ry and three speak and
four lots of these things
there are people involved or founders or
corporations whose politics are not in
line with mine but my view is my content
in more places without requiring a lot
more work for our team is good I can
increase my reach I can get my content
in front of people that's a good thing
that was my thought with the thing spot
partnership now the launch of think spot
got delayed multiple times I think at
first it was going to be early August
then late August then I don't even know
when it launched I think it was maybe in
October but eventually it launched and
when think spot launched it launched
with really no other contributors that I
think were well aligned with the David
Pakman show engagement was very low and
I'll be honest my ability to engage with
the platform is also low because we're
very busy at the end of the day and then
I saw this may actually be an acutely
bad platform for us to be on it's not
like some of these others some of these
other platforms where there are tons of
contributors and I'm there putting up my
stuff it was like eight contributors
that were being promoted one of those
contributors is Jordan Peterson's
daughter whose content was being sold
for even more than mine when I which I
found sort of jarring and and in
Congress I think her content is mostly
around eating like a meat only diet or
something like that so long story short
I respectfully told them I don't think
this is the right platform for me the
way it's shaken out there's no real
cadre of other contributors that are
kind of doing what we're doing at the
level we're doing it in our space I
don't think it's helping me they also
said we're going to be transitioning
from a subscription model to more of a
micro payments model that makes it even
less suited for us because we're already
on a bunch of those and I don't want to
spread our micro payment platforms too
thin so as far as I've been told you can
no longer subscribe to me on think spot
they are in the process of removing my
content altogether and this is sort of
more in line with what's going to be our
2020 strategy which is now I think we
are at a point where I'm not looking to
get on more and more and more platforms
and spread ourselves really thin I'm
reeling in the platforms that we're on
we're gonna focus on a few platforms
that are working well for us so we're
gonna try to grow YouTube we're gonna
try to grow Facebook and Instagram video
we're going to grow the pod
cast that will be the focus now I got a
couple of questions on Twitter saying
David are you going to return the money
the first answer is we never got any
money I mean we didn't get any money for
signing up and we were getting a cut of
subscriptions four people signed up I
never got any money
I don't know what the payment schedule
is supposed to be there's no money to
return but beyond that I don't know why
I would return money like if people
don't like this platform me keeping
money gives them less money you'd think
he would want me to do that but in any
case there is no money for people got
paid subscriptions and none of the money
ever came to me and I don't predict that
it ever will so that's that and no I
also am NOT joining gave Reubens new
platform either I don't know much about
that one but I can assure you I am not
involved and that is the thought is the
story would think spot one of our
sponsors is privacy calm they're giving
you $5.00 when you sign up for their
completely free service at privacy calm
slash Pakman I've been using privacy for
a little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before it's a lifesaver
and here's how it works takes just a
couple of minutes to set up any time you
buy something online or on the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plugin let you give each
company a randomized virtual credit card
number that you create out of thin air
it'll even autofill the card number with
one click and the payment is taken out
of your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to 12 of these virtual credit
cards a month you can set spending
limits you can freeze them you can
delete them any time you want so when
you do this it means you're not going to
be charged when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number right after using it which for
instance I love using free trials
because I know I won't be charged when
the trial is over if I use a virtual
credit card number you're keeping your
identity private by not telling
companies who you are you're keeping
your bank or credit card info protected
against data breaches and identity theft
and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but if you want privacy also
offers a $10 a month plan that gives you
one percent cashback and lets you create
36 credit cards a month and a $25 a
month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create 60 card
numbers a month and much more but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like I
said you'll get $5 to spend when you
sign up at privacy calm slash Pakman